round one of the 2017 US Chess  Championships here in st. Louis in the  open section one of the pre-tournament  favourites Hikaru Nakamura defeated  Olympic teammate Ray Robson while Wesley  sold the hottest player in the world  continued his amazing run by crushing  Alexander Chuvalo and reaffirming his  recent domination at the top of the  chess world from the woman's side Casa  of Abraham Yan seeking her first  championship made quick work of the  youngster a move over good while the  shock of the round saw four-time  champion hennas adorned ski commits an  unbelievable blunder against the  precocious teenager get it for you  catapulting the youngster into a tie for  first place the strongest and richest US  Championship in history promises to be  one of the most exciting yet rounds ooh  live from st. Louis coming up next